this gent will be with us uh once again
he was with us the last time we did a
televised draft on nfl network in
tennessee it was dynamite to have him on
the set then
can't wait to have him with everybody on
uh
on the friday night of draft coverage
from ohio from
fox sports joel klatt how are you joel
good man how are you
better for talking to you this is
exciting we're back in the saddle
we're back at it pleasure's all on this
side of the table no please
joel i enjoyed it i enjoyed your your
you know your professionalism your your
points just your
your sense of humor the camaraderie and
all of that and then
you know for you to come on the show as
well the day of and say that daniel
jones's choice by the giants was going
to set the franchise back years you you
don't mince words
you don't miss words at all joel well
you know i'm
i'm i'm not accurate all the time well i
will tell you what i think
no i know that but but we're we're kind
of two years in and
you know there are some people wondering
that if trey lance falls to 11
or or somebody falls to 11 the giant
should do something like that
but the owner squelched that saying
daniel jones can be a playoff
quarterback i guess let's
let's start there just to throw your
curve right off the bat you thought we'd
talk trevor lawrence right off the bat
but what do you what do you make of the
evaluation from just a couple of years
ago that draft class kyla murray him
and so many more and now that we're two
seasons in
do you think we can make an evaluation
on any of these guys just yet
what do you think um i mean it's it can
be so difficult right and
and this is where i think the the part
of the conversation
that frustrates me that we don't have it
uh
around the draft time and and one it's
not sexy and two it's
it's really difficult to have but the
context of fit
you know and where these these players
are going what the cap issues are with
those organization what the coaching
staff issues are what the front office
issues are what the ownership issues are
all of those things matter
and i think too many times we we look at
the quarterback position
we think that they're either going to
succeed or fail in a vacuum and that's
that's clearly not the case um you know
and when i look back i still
like i still am in awe of what kyler
murray does on the field
and there were a lot of conversations
rich and i remember
having them i don't remember if we had
it on on the desk that night
but just about his size and it's like
well can it
can it work right well i think what
we're starting to see
is is some of those old-school
questions of you know too small to
succeed
and this or that what regardless of
position have started to be thrown out
and and i believe that's because the
modern style of the game both at the
college level and in the nfl
is more of hybrid players now outside of
a few quarterbacks we're not seeing
careers last quite as long so
you know i think that you can have
different styles and succeed
regardless of position so looking back i
thought that the giants
used more of an old-school mentality to
go get the guy that they felt like was
going to own the game from the pocket
and be the
the tom brady-esque peyton manning-esque
type of quarterback
and and to be honest i i think that the
jury is
is very much still in deliberation about
whether
daniel jones is working with the new
york giants and then and then in terms
of you know quarterback size in this
year's class there's really nobody
to comp with kyla murray it's it's it's
different i guess
in a way that the the size question
involves devante smith
your heisman trophy winner right and and
um and where he fits in in an offense so
again
just uh we'll obviously get to the
quarterbacks what do you think of the
wide receiver class we're assuming jamar
chase is gonna go
and be paired up with his old college
quarterback at five um
and that if he doesn't then that affects
what the dolphins might do at six
there's the kyle pitts
pass catcher of it all but what do you
think about the heisman trophy winner
versus waddle and all of that
joel well i i love devonta smith i i
have him in my top
10 of overall players in the entire
draft and i think
you know i've said this a couple of
different spots but i i really do
believe
deep down that his success is going to
be reliant
on the the ability of his
play caller and and offensive
coordinator play designer
the ability of that that guy to be
creative and and the reason is is
because
rich when you go back and you watch
alabama play one of the things that they
did such a great
job of even after jalen waddle was
injured and devonte smith was
was you know one of not not the only but
like he was kind of the biggest threat
on the field
and and so you would think that defenses
were going to focus in on that but it
was impossible for them to do that
because of the the multitude of
different ways that steve sarkeesian
used him and not just used him it's not
just how you get the ball to him but
it's also
where he's aligned on the field and when
you're 166 pounds soaking wet
wet here you've got to be off the line
of scrimmage
for the majority of the time you've got
to be in motion both all the way across
the ball and in what i would call return
motion to the ball and back to that same
spot
you've got to get the ball in in several
different ways whether it's bubble
screens jet screens you got to get the
ball handed to you on a jet sweep
you can be coming across the field on a
shallow cross he can work this slot he
can go on a corner round so he's got to
do all those things
sometimes the hubris of the nfl play
caller and even
executive drives me nuts because they'll
draft the player and it's like well we
took this
wide receiver because he was our best
wide receiver on the board and then they
put him in an offense where he's a
static outside player
see i don't think devante smith is going
to be a great static outside wide
receiver in the nfl because of his size
so why would you attempt that if you
were going to draft him having a plan
for these players is paramount um if you
look at some of these edge rushers
they're going to have to have a plan in
place if you look at a guy like
oh let's say jeremiah from notre dame
you know he's a hybrid style defender is
he a safety yeah i don't know is he a
linebacker
i don't know but he's a football player
jesse so you've got to have a plan
surrounding him i think that
very much the similar conversation to
simmons last year from clemens the great
you know
hybrid defender so is davonte smith too
small no
no so long as his offensive play caller
understands the necessity of having him
line up
uh in in a number of different places
from snap to snap joel klatt
fox sports and my colleague for night
two
of the nfl draft he will be joining me
charles davis and
daniel jeremiah on nfl network uh one
week from friday for
night two rounds two and three right
here on the rich eisen show
so let's get into who you think the
49ers are targeting at three
and who they essentially would have been
happy with getting when they made that
maneuver on zack wilson's pro day
the day that we all assumed the jets uh
fell completely head over heels we're
definitely taking him we're trading sam
darnold away in love with zach wilson
your thoughts
on that subject joel clad well
i think it's kind of a foregone
conclusion what's happening in the top
two pick so i think that you're right
49ers movement i think clearly was
for a specific player and or andor
and and this is where i feel like maybe
we haven't dug
quite deep enough and or to be in a
position
to be the one that dictates where the
rest of them go
right so it's it's not enough so i've
heard a couple of people say
well denver doesn't have to move because
they like
they like all these guys yeah but why
let somebody else make that decision for
you
right doesn't that seem like a position
that you should probably make that
decision for yourself
now maybe some organizations are scared
to do that maybe they're a little
gun-shy certainly denver might fall into
that category after all the swings and
misses that they've had
uh posted the peyton manning era um
there in denver but having said that i i
think that that san francisco made that
move
because john lynch wanted to control the
table
he wanted to be in the first seat of the
blackjack table not allow somebody to
bust in front of him
just so that he could get a card that he
didn't you know realize that he wanted
um a lot of analogies to say i
i can see them going in any number of
different directions i always have a
hard time in my role
taking my own opinion out of it right
rich
sure you know because i'm hearing that
they really like max jones and in the
back of my mind i'm like
but he's not the best prospect of the
three so that doesn't make any sense to
me
um not that he's a bad prospect i love
mack jones
i love his anticipation he throws with
great touch
um he controls the game from the pocket
he ran an offense
not all that dissimilar to what he would
be afforded the opportunity to run in
san francisco
but having said that he doesn't have the
size and talent that these other guys do
specifically trey lance and justin
fields
i think that the knocks on justin fields
and the the
narratives surrounding justin fields
have been completely blown out of
proportion and are completely false he's
my second best quarterback
overall in the draft right behind trevor
lawrence
in fact when he played clemson this last
year and was putting on
a historically great performance in that
semi-final
after it looked like he was you're
playing with a lacerated kidney or a
bursted spleen
ruptured slain remember after that hit
there was conversations about hey is he
making a push to the number one spot one
of my biggest pet peeves with this
entire
um you know
draft process is when there's all this
movement
after guys are actually on the field
justin fields is a phenomenal player we
haven't seen his size and speed and
accuracy down the field maybe ever
fields led the power five in
back-to-back years in terms of his
production through the year 70 percent
one year 72 percent the other
he was attacking down the field his
yards per attempt were way
up there he can run it he can do all of
those things he has one bad game against
indiana in a year in which they don't
have a fall camp
he's pressing to get himself back into
the heisman trophy race and get his team
back on the footing where they can go to
the playoff and everyone wants to throw
him down the draft board i
i don't quite understand it so if i was
making the selection for the 49ers i
would select justin fields i think he's
the best prospect at the spot
but i i am hearing as is everybody that
they love
mac jones and i think it's because kyle
shanahan believes that he can come in
and contribute and not only contribute
but play right away
well in the many uh the ohio state games
that you call
for fox with gus joel klatt including
the ones that break my heart
um did you ever hear the concept of
justin fields last in
first out this is a problem this isn't
never right
never and to give you some context i
don't just like
call a lot of i called ten of his games
in the last two years right
you know and and i never once heard it i
was also there
when he first stepped on campus i i flew
out to columbus just to watch him
practice in person because i knew i
would be covering a lot of his games and
i stood with ryan day at the time and
mike urchich who has since moved on
who was the quarterback coach former
offensive coordinator at oklahoma state
we i've talked about justin field ad
nauseum with these guys
and never one time whether it was mick
moriarty the strength coach ryan day
mike your chance any of his coaches
never one time ever
did anyone even hint at that being an
issue so when i heard that i was
dumbfounded
i think it's a it's a totally false
narrative and
and i think it's it's a dangerous
narrative to perpetuate hopefully that's
that's not the case anymore as most of
us who
who are in the know have come out and
and said the truth
but i also want to break the narrative
of what fields is
as as a player on the field so many
people are like well he's one of these
ohio state quarterbacks rich i gave you
the percentage of of air production
right 70 72 percent
of his production was through the air he
was attacking down the field he's
accurate down the field he did that
by the way without throwing um uh
interceptions to a great degree remember
he played basically the whole season 40
touchdowns one interception leading into
the semi-final game against clemson two
years ago
it was so different than dwayne haskins
dwayne haskins barely 50
of his production came through the year
he was reliant on paris campbell and
terry mclaren
and these guys to create after the catch
okay so he was 41st i believe in the
power five in his production
passing production coming through the
air justin fields was number one
far different players i think they were
utilized in a different way
and i don't think that they're similar
at all yeah
you know i mean and and just to put a
button on this
you know coaches would say to you and
you can't because i'm sure people will
be
out of course the coaches aren't going
to denigrate their guy
they wouldn't denigrate their guy to you
they would say something along the lines
of yeah there's been a couple times
where we have to work on
you know him you know getting in the
film room there's a couple times where
we need to work on him you know
getting there um showing up and being
one of the first but you know
it's not all the time but we're working
on that like that's the way they would
say something to you before a game
right over exactly right that's exactly
right and in fact
and i have had that put to me this
verbatim not about fields but about
other players is is he's learning how to
become a better worker
that's right that is the universal code
right and it's just like everyone nods
and we know what that means
and again i never sniffed that comment
whatsoever
and and just to put a button on this not
that you want to just talk about fields
no no
the only reason the entire conference
played football was because of his
leadership
if you're a last in first out you don't
fight that hard to get on the field
uh like he did for the big ten last fall
so then let's talk lance real quick
uh joel clack because you know in a way
he's kind of like well he comes from
carson wentz's school and look what
happened to wence and all that and
they're two
you know completely different humans uh
what
i i'm hearing he is really
uh a sponge he is curious he is
eager to get better he is terrific he's
got a huge ceiling
and the question is where where do you
think he would be best
a best fit to use that phrase before i
let you go
atop this draft in a couple of thursdays
joel
yeah i that the fit part is is a great
question and if i knew that i would be
making
a lot more money than i am working for
some organization
right i i i do i do think this guy's
fabulous
oh rich i love his game like it like i
said
or you said he's a sponge he's blowing
people away in his meetings whether
they're zoom or in person he
he has done a fabulous job during this
process
he's a film junkie he loves the sport he
ran a pro scheme he controlled his own
protections
uh he makes all the throws he's big he's
tough he's athletic
he's a quality leader he's everything
that you want there's no doubt
i think that the only concern that i'm
running into out there is the fact that
he's just a a quarterback infant as it
pertains to reps
because it's a reps position and he's
he's thrown 318 passes in his college
career that's next to nothing did you
know that the last 10 super bowl winning
quarterbacks if you average out their
college career they average around
33 starts 1200 passing attempts right
around 700 completions 60 plus
touchdowns
it's an experienced quarterback that
generally goes from college
into the nfl and then has success
leading the locker room to win a super
bowl
in fact one of the players that's really
low on that list as far as
is his his reps in college is actually
brady
and and you look at some of the other
guys and they so
his experience level might be a concern
but every other category he has just
been checking off those boxes and
everyone's falling in love with them i i
assume to be honest with you i assume
that
that we might have some fireworks at
atlanta's spots yes
the fact that i don't know if they want
to have someone sitting behind matt ryan
when they can't move
him you know so on and so forth so you
know i could see someone trying to dive
up there
but then that takes atlanta out of the
kyle pitts running potentially and
and i would be again that's the atlanta
conundrum
lance is the sponge and he is got such a
huge upside and he does need the time to
i guess
uh um mature marinate however you want
to put it for
for for the concept but the idea of
putting pits
with calvin ridley and you know
um and julio jones and matt ryan
and haydenhurst and two tight ends go to
work
as matt's got that closing window of
opportunity that sounds
so delicious to me to be honest well and
they're in such a bad cap situation
that don't you sense that it's like well
why would you try to rebuild now when
you can't do anything
right i mean like they're kind of stuck
so why not just take a huge swing with a
veteran quarterback that's been an mvp
gotten you there before probably
well definitely should have won that
super bowl you know you give him
a player like that who knows what you
could do offensively
joel thanks for the time greatly
appreciate it i will see you in ohio
i'll see you
potentially i guess imagine maybe on a
zoom before then or two
and then uh sure and i'll see you out
there i look forward to it joel
i i love working with you and i look
forward to doing it again
well likewise rich can't wait but right
back at you joel cloud at joel cloud on
twitter follow him i do too
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here